Çeviri: Gözde Zülal Solak
Gözden geçirme: Suleyman Cengiz
İki hafta kaldı, bu ülkenin sistemi
değişecek mi değişmeyecek mi?
Şunun şurasında 15 gün sonra,
umuyorum ki, hepimiz sandığa
gideceğiz ve oyumuzu vereceğiz.
Hepimizin, şu anda
bu salonda bulunan iki bin küsur
kişinin kafasında eminim
"acaba ne çıkacak?" vardır.
Ama bir o kadar da
eminim, herkesin olmasa bile,
asgari yüzde sekseninin kafasında
"peki, ya benim istediğim sonuç çıkmazsa?
Ben bu ülkeyi terk mi edeyim?
Burada mı kalayım?"
sorunsalı geziniyordur.
Kimimiz diyoruz ki,
"Ya falanca ülkede 500 bin euro
verdiğinde 10 yıl oturma izni veriyorlar;
filanca ülkeye git ev al oradan,
vatandaşlık veriyorlar.
Ya bu yaştan sonra ne evi arkadaş,
ben başka yerde yaşayamam,
en iyisi ben çocukları
yollayayım onlar kapağı atsın."
"Kapağı atmak."
Gitmek mi, kalmak mı?
Çok büyük sorunsalı şu anda bu ülkenin.
Ama sadece şu anda değil, tarih boyunca da
büyük bir sorunsalı olmuş.
Aslında bu topraklar bir göç yatağı,
belki nihai vatan oldu bizlere,
ama aynı zamanda bir göç yatağı da oldu.
Binlerce yıl öncesinden
göçebe kavimler geldiler,
buralara yerleştiler,
buralardan gittiler geçtiler.
Aynı zamanda bu ülke,
hem el salladı gidenlerine,
hem de bir taraftan hoş geldin dedi.
Belki de beyinlerimizin
kuranderde kalması bu yüzdendir,
iki kapı da açık çünkü genelde.
Yani şöyle gözlerinizi kapatın isterseniz,
siyah beyaz günlere gidelim.
Fotoğraf kullanmak istemedim,
çünkü hakikaten içimden gelmedi
iki hafta sonrayı düşündüğümden.
Gözünüzü kapatın,
şöyle 1949'a götüreyim ben sizi.
Siyah beyaz, Dolmabahçe
Sarayı'nın önünü hayal edin,
o caddeyi.
Bir sevinç, bir alkış, bir çığlık,
anam ne oluyor diye bakıyorsunuz.
Sanayi devriminden yıllar yıllar
sonra üstüne üç kuşak olmuş,
ülkeye ilk traktör geliyor.
Çok güzel, yani sanayileşmeye
karşı değiliz, tamam.
Büyük bir sevinçle karşılandı
ve bağrına basıldı bu traktör.
Ama öyle olmadı.
Çünkü bunun negatif tarafları da oldu.
Köylere gidildiğinde
bu traktörle, pek çok işçi
traktör yüzünden işsiz kaldı.
Ne yaptılar?
Taşı toprağı altın
dedikleri şehre geldiler.
Onların gelişiyle beraber,
-- tabii ki onlar sorumlu değil,
onlar karınlarını doyurma derdinde --
onların gelişiyle beraber,
rant kavramı girdi hayatımıza.
Çünkü, evleri olanlar
artık daha fazla kira ister oldular.
Satmak için, çok daha
fazla paralar ister oldular.
Arsalar pahalandı.
E ne yaptı bu insanlar?
Gecekondu kurdular.
Çünkü bir dam arayışındaydılar.
Çarpık kentleşme, iş ve işçi bulma kurumu
önündeki uzun kuyruklar,
bozulan sağlık, eğitim sistemi,
işte bunlar, bir traktörün
bu ülkeye girmesiyle
kendini gösterdi.
Ve o günden bu güne,
hâlâ çarpık şehirleşmenin
kurbanlarıyız hep beraber.
Bugün buraya gelirken
yaşadığınız trafik çilesi de
bunun aslında bir parçası.
O kadar küçümsemeyelim,
bir milyon kişi köyünden
kente göç etti.
O zaman Türkiye'nin nüfusu
-- bu beş yılda oluyor, 50 - 55
yılları arasında -- 21 milyondu.
Yani 21'de birimiz göç etti
ve çoğumuz o köyde
durup onlara el salladı.
Gelelim 1961'e.
Yine hatırlarsınız o kareyi,
sizin hayalinize bırakıyorum.
Hani Sirkeci garından,
trenlerden, bizim durup
el salladığımız kare vardı ya.
Almanya'ya göçen işçilerimiz.
Çünkü bir kısmının karnı hâlâ doymamıştı.
Hâlâ ekmek arayışındalardı
ve kasabasını dahi görmeden
bir başka dilin konuşulduğu
bambaşka bir yere gitti.
O da 1961 - 1974 yılları arasında 13 yılda
bir milyon kişi göçtü.
Bugün 3 milyon Türk yaşıyor Almanya'da.
Gelelim 1980'e.
Bir darbe yaşandı,
Türkiye'nin kara tarihi.
Ve orada işkence görmemek adına,
hapse düşmemek adına,
buradan kaçan pek çok
entelektüel, aydın ve sanatçı vardı.
Çoğu Avrupa'ya, birçoğu da
Kuzey Avrupa'ya yerleşti.
Biz yine durduk ve onlara el salladık.
Resmi rakamlara göre 35 bin,
ama Birleşmiş Milletler'e
göre 105 bin aydınımız ülkeyi terk etti.
Kaçtılar.
Kaçmak zorunda kaldılar.
Tabii her zaman el sallayan olmadık,
bazen de kapıyı açıp hoş geldin dedik.
Bu ülke çok kişiyi misafir etti.
1917 yılında Bolşevik Devrimi'nden
kaçan Ruslar buraya sığındı.
İkinci Dünya Savaşı
öncesinde Hitler faşizminden
kaçan Almanlar buraya sığındı.
Hitler'in işgal ettiği ülkelerden kaçan
Avusturyalılar buraya sığındı.
Bosna Hersek savaşında Boşnaklar,
Bulgar soydaşlarımız, Afgan mülteciler
buraya sığındı.
Ve son olarak da Suriyeliler.
Şimdi, gitmek öyle bir eylemdir ki,
gitmeyi düşündüğünüz
zaman, rahat olmayı istersiniz.
Spor ayakkabınızı, değil mi,
lüks pabucunuzu giyer gidersiniz.
Böyle bavulunuzu çekersiniz,
havaalanına gidersiniz.
Ama kaçtığınız zaman ayağınızda
ne olduğuna bakmazsınız.
Suriyeliler için de öyle oldu.
Çoğu çıplak ayaklı,
bir kısmı terlikleriyle,
çocuklarını kaptıkları gibi,
bir de yanlarına salça bidonlarını alarak
-- çünkü bir ekmek bulduğunuzda karnınızı
onunla doyurabilirsiniz ve
uzun süre saklayabilirsiniz o salçayı --
kaçtılar.
Türkiye 3 milyon Suriyeliyi
misafir ediyor şu anda.
Bunların 1 milyonu çocuk
ve o çocukların yarısı eğitim görmüyor.
Ama biz onlara kapımızı açtık,
öyle ya da böyle,
beğenin ya da beğenmeyin.
O zaman, bu soruyu
şöyle de sormak gerekiyor;
gitmek mi kalmak mı,
yoksa gitmek mi kaçmak mı?
Ben buna çok geç
karar verebilmiş biriyim,
çünkü benim hayatımın büyük bölümü,
oturup böyle durup
gidenlere el sallamakla geçti.
Ben böyle kaldım hep.
Sekiz yaşındaydım, aynı evde yaşıyorduk,
anneannem öldü,
bir de realist bir çocuktum.
Ölüsünü görmek istedim,
çünkü vedalaşmak istedim,
ona el sallamak istedim.
Annem de benim kadar
realistmiş, beni yanına götürdü.
Ve bana öğretti, dedi ki:
"Bak önce biri öldüğünde
gözünü kaparsın.
Sonra çenesini buradan
bir eşarpla bağlarsın ki
çenesi düşer ölünün." dedi.
Sonra ayaklarının baş parmaklarını
birbirine bağlarsın dedi.
Gösterdi, sonra da biliyorsan
duasını okursun dedi.
Belki kendi ölümüne hazırlık ediyordu.
Sonra kansere yakalandı annem.
Türkiye'de ömrü yok dediler.
Babam varını yoğunu satıp
annemi Londra'ya götürdü
ve dört yıl yaşatabildi.
On iki yaşındaydım annemi kaybettiğimde.
Çok yanına gitmek
ve onunla vedalaşmak istedim,
ama babam ve arkadaşları
travmatik olabileceğini benim için
düşündüklerinden, annemi göstermediler.
Ve ben yıllar boyunca
annemin bir gün geri döneceğini,
bir yerlerde yaşadığını hayal ettim.
Sonra 18 yaşına geldim.
Ay ben de acıların çocuğu gibi anlatıyorum
hakikaten anlatınca insana
böyle bir fena geliyor.
Ama öyle.
(Gülüşmeler)
18 yaşına geldim, babaannem öldü.
Babam bir yurt dışı seyahatindeydi,
babaannemle aynı evdeydik.
Uyandığımda onun ölüsünü buldum.
Uykusunda öldüğünü diliyorum hâlâ.
En güzel ölümlerden biri
olduğunu düşünüyorum.
Kimse yoktu, ben, bana öğretildiği gibi
gözünü kapattım, çenesini bağladım,
ayaklarını bağladım
ve başında duasını okudum.
Sonra babamın arkadaşlarını arayıp
morga kaldırılmasını
sağladım babam gelene kadar.
Sonra babamı kaybettim.
Ambulansla götürüldüğü için
-- bir kalp kriziydi --
onunla ancak morgda vedalaşabildim.
Yanına girdim elini tuttum,
kulağına seni seviyorum dedim
ve ona da, yine el salladım.
Eliniz mahkûm, istiyorsanız sallamayın.
Hayat size bunu zorla yaptırıyor zaten.
Sonra, tam içimden dedim ki
yeter artık, ben de gitmeliyim,
birileri de benim arkamdan el sallamalı.
Ve o sırada eşim Londra'da bir iş buldu.
O gidince ben de uzun
yıllardır çalıştığım TRT'den
istifa ettim ve gittim.
200 metrekare lüks bir
evde yaşıyordum Ankara'da.
O bavulu hazırlamak çok travmatikti.
Çünkü o gün karar verdim, yıl 2003'dü,
iki tane bavulla gideceğim
ve içinde sadece giysilerim olacak.
Bütün çatalımı, bardağımı,
kanepemi, sevdiğim bütün
eşyaları bir büyükelçinin
üçüncü kâtibesine kiraya verdim
ve küçücük bir eve,
gecekondudan bozma,
yatağı kırık, çarşafı
delik, bardağı kırık, Londra'da
-- çünkü paramız ona yetiyor,
çünkü zaten hayat orada öyle minimal --
yerleştik.
7 yıl yaşadım Londra'da ve
yine 2010 yılında Bloomberg'den
teklif gelince Bloomberg
HT'ye gelmek üzere bir bavulla
Türkiye'ye geldim.
Ve 2003 yılından bu yana
sadece bavulla yaşıyorum.
Eşya almıyorum.
Mobilyalı evlerde oturuyorum.
Çünkü bir kere hareket etmeye
ve el sallamaya başladığınız zaman,
vedalara alıştığınız zaman,
o kanepenin, o çatalın, o bıçağın
size sanal kökler
yarattığını görüyorsunuz.
Bir kanepe ya da bir ev ya da
bir dam benim köküm olmamalı.
Benim gerçek köküm
ailem, ki onları zaten kaybettim,
sonra eşimin de
arkasından el salladım, veda ettim.
Sonuç itibariyle, o zaman
bir eşya benim köküm olmamalı
diye düşündüm ve bavulumla
yaşamaya karar verdim.
Hani telefonlarınızdaki emojiler var ya,
onlardan bilir misiniz,
bir tane kırmızı balon vardır.
O benim işte.
Kendimi ona çok benzetiyorum.
Helyumla doldurulmuş,
böyle alttan ipi var,
ayakta tek başına duruyor.
Bir kökü de yok, gidebilir de,
ama kalmayı seçiyor.
Esma ile tanıştırayım sizi,
8 yaşında ve genelde
Gezi Parkı'nda yaşıyor.
O da kendine bir eğitim
yuvası, bir dam arayışı içinde.
Burada var olmaya
çalışıyor ve çöpten bulduğu
bu topuklu ayakkabılarla
-- herhangi birimizin artık
beğenmeyerek attığı
topuklu ayakkabılarla --
belki de kadın olmak,
belki de güzel hissetmek,
belki de bastığı yeri artık sağlam
düşünerek kendi istediği gibi
yüksekten basabilmek
için bunlarla poz veriyor.
Birinden de hoşlanıyor,
o da 8 yaşında yine onun yaşında
ama başka bir kız daha var 8 yaşında,
o, o çocuktan hoşlandığı için
aralarına girmemeyi tercih ediyor.
Esma'nın hikâyesi böyle.
Beni 8 yaşında anneannemi
kaybettiğim güne götürdü.
Ben de topuklularımla
yaşamayı tercih ediyorum.
Çünkü ben gitmeyeceğim arkadaşlar.
Çünkü ben buraya hayallerim için döndüm.
Çünkü ben Londra'ya
hayallerim için gittim.
Çünkü ben buraya dönmek için gittim.
Çünkü ne yazık ki çifte standartlıyız.
Ben Ankara'dan, istediğiniz
kadar başarılı olun,
İstanbul'a gelseydim muhabir
olarak ya da televizyoncu olarak,
bu kadar havalı getirilmeyecektim.
Londra üstünden geldiğim zaman
bir şaşaalı geldim ki sormayın.
Sanki çok acayip biri geliyor.
Altı üstü yaptığımız iş belli.
Ama böyleydi ve ben gerçekten
hem dünya insanı olabilmek için,
hem dünyayı tanıyabilmek,
başka kültürler görebilmek için,
ama hiç değilse bir kere
el sallayabilmek için,
ben de gidiyorum diyebilmek
için dünyaya, gittim.
Ve hayal ettiğim gibi,
bu sahnede olmayı, bu işi yapmayı
hayal ediyordum.
Hâlâ da hayallerim var.
Mesela, bütün kadınlara
ekonomiyi sevdirmeyi hayal ediyorum.
Bunu gerçekten --
çünkü kadınlar ekonomiyi sevip
öğrenirse, bu ülke kurtulur onu biliyorum.
Mesela,
yaşlıların, kimsesiz çocukların
ve sokak hayvanlarının
birbirinden zincirleme
sorumlu olacağı bir köy
kurmak istiyorum ölmeden önce.
Çünkü hepsinin birbirini sahiplenmeye
ihtiyacı olduğunu düşünüyorum.
Sorum şu size şimdi:
Gitmek mi kalmak mı değil,
siz karar verin,
gitmek mi kaçmak mı?
Çünkü kaçmak hiçbir
zaman bir hayal olamaz.
Hele de istediğiniz
ya da istemediğiniz bir
yönetim var diye, burada
azınlığa düştüğümüzü düşünerek
bir başka ülkede azınlığın dahi azınlığı
olup olmayacağımızı bilmeden,
belki de hiç daha bugüne kadar
evimizi dahi değiştirmediğimiz
bir hayatta, kaçmak bir hayal olamaz.
Evet, caz şarkıcısı olmak
istiyorsunuzdur ve dünya çapında
olmak istiyorsunuzdur,
gidin New Orleans'a.
Çok iyi bir makine mühendisi
olmak için gidin Almanya'ya.
Hep beraber gidelim.
Ama istediğimiz bir şeyler
istediğimiz gibi gitmiyor diye
gitmekse eğer bütün hayalimiz,
o zaman dönüp aynaya bakalım.
Dönüp bakalım.
Gerçekten gidiyor muyuz,
yoksa biz kaçıyor muyuz?
Ya da kurduğumuz hayal kaçmak üzerine mi?
Vallahi ben -- bana fikrimi
sorarsanız, naçizane hiçbirinizin
kafasına girip hiçbir şey
diyemem, haddim değil --
ama ben, beni bırakmayın derim.
Şöyle ki --
(Alkış)
Bu benim işte.
Bu, uçan balon değil.
Emojideki uçan balon.
Gittiğiniz takdirde, giderseniz, ki çünkü
bu salondaki iki bin küsür
kişi eğer buraya bizi dinlemeye
geldiyseniz, biz de
size konuşma yapmaya çıktıysak,
biz bu memlekette
birbirimize emanetiz demektir.
Eğer giderseniz --
(Alkış)
Eğer giderseniz,
bunun içindeki helyum olmaz.
Siz benim helyumumsunuz.
Biz de sizin helyumunuz.
Biz birbirimizin helyumuyuz.
Bunu havaya kaldırmak için,
bunu düz tutabilmek için.
Yoksa böyle, hakikaten,
bu balon böyle kalacak.
Ve ben hiçbirinizin arkasından
el sallamak istemiyorum.
Hiçbirinizi hiçbir yere, artık bu yaştan
sonra, göndermek istemiyorum.
Hele hele, buraya gelecek
ve güneşli bir Cumartesi'ni burada
birlikte geçirecek bu
değerli insanların kaçmasını
hiç istemiyorum.
Çünkü kaçmayı hiçbirimize yakıştırmıyorum.
(Alkış)